well I'm in the court now the brothers
are in one of the courtrooms at the back
here as their lawyers try to argue that
they should be released they've been in
detention here since the end of December
as police continue an investigation into
allegations of human trafficking and
rape alongside them to Romanian women
who were also arrested at that time and
during the course of the last six to
eight weeks we've seen the police here
raid properties related to the Tate
Brothers they've seized money and goods
of an estimated value of around 4
million dollars now all of those who are
in court today deny all of the
allegations against them and when they
were arriving I shouted a question to
Andrew Tate have a listen
did you hurt any women Mr Tate
are you innocent Mr Tate
are you confident you're going to be
released today
so as we speak they are laying out their
case and in the next few hours we will
hear if they've been successful if they
will be released or if they'll continue
to be held here until the end of
February